There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of the
most-hyped products from August
to test for ourselves.
I've been seeing these
gorgeous holo glosses
from Queen Cosmetics all over TikTok.
Of course, I had to get three of them.
These glosses are just
as beautiful in person.
They honestly feel fine on the lips,
as long as you don't apply too much.
I packed on this Electric shade,
and it did feel a little gritty,
so I recommend only doing
one to two thin layers
to avoid that, but these are so cool.
They look good on their own
but even better over lipstick,
especially darker colors.
This is the new Fenty Beauty Eaze Drop'Lit
All-Over Glow Enhancer.
It can be worn on its own
to reduce the look of pores
or mixed into foundation
for some added glow.
Using this on its own,
I honestly wasn't very impressed.
I don't think my pores
were necessarily blurred,
and I felt like my skin
didn't look that glowy.
It kind of just looked
like I applied moisturizer.
I think this worked better
when mixed into a foundation.
I mixed it with my Eaze
Drop Blurring Skin Tint,
which I love, and I
noticed it gave my skin
a nice little glow.
This skin tint is more on the matte side,
so I do like that the glow
enhancer made it more dewy.
However, I don't think
it's such a big difference
that I can justify buying this product.
It kind of just feels like an extra step
that doesn't add much.
Item Beauty is Addison Rae's beauty brand.
People rave about its lip oils,
so I figured I'd test it out
with a couple of other products too.
So, this is the Lip Quip
moisturizing lip oil.
Let me start out by
saying it smells amazing,
kind of peachy.
The color was actually
a little more pigmented
than I expected for a lip oil,
but I thought it was so pretty.
The formula is on the thicker side.
It feels super nourishing
and just makes your lips look so juicy,
so I am really into this.
This is going in my bag.
Next I tried the Boost
Juice dual-ended lash primer
and colored mascara.
So you can use this as a lash
primer or colored mascara.
The lilac side is for volume,
and the blue side is for lengthening.
I have to admit I much
preferred the blue side
as just a colored mascara.
I feel like once I applied
regular mascara on top of it,
my lashes just kind of lumped together.
The lilac side barely
showed up on my lashes,
but it worked much
better as a lash primer.
I also tried the Blushin Like cream blush.
It's supposed to be a
cream-to-powder formula,
but it just kind of feels like a powder.
I used my sponge to apply it at first,
but it just kind of
looked a little splotchy.
It worked much better with a brush.
You can also apply it to the lips,
and it was honestly cute.
It's buildable, which I like,
but I don't feel like
this is anything special.
ColourPop drops new stuff,
like, every other day,
but these Graphix ink
liners caught my eye.
I really like this tip. I's
supersharp and flexible.
I am horrible at doing any
kind of liner situation,
so I was really glad
that this tip kind of did the work for me.
However, the color payoff
on these is not great.
I found myself layering up the product
for full color payoff,
and with this formula,
the more you layer, the
more textured it looks.
It sucks because these are colors
that I don't really see
a lot of in eyeliner,
but this formula is just not my favorite.
IT Cosmetics just dropped another
Love is the Foundation brush.
I think it drops one of these a year.
I have one from a previous
year that I really love,
but they're actually not the same.
This new one is less dense
and more flexible than my old one,
and I also feel like the bristles
on this new one are longer.
I used it to apply my foundation,
and I was really happy with how fast
it blended everything in
without looking streaky.
It also worked great with my concealer.
I didn't lose any coverage with this brush
because it didn't absorb the product.
I think I actually like this new one
better than my old one.
I tried a couple of
products from J.Cat Beauty.
Let's talk about this blush first.
This color is so pretty.
It's like an orangey pink
with a bunch of gold shimmer in it,
so you get this very buildable color
with some added glow.
I can definitely see this color working
for so many different skin tones.
The Mood Flick holo-sparkle lip balm
is one of those
color-changing lip products.
I honestly thought these
would be more glittery,
but I think it just looked metallic on me.
They do actually feel pretty
moisturizing on the lips.
I was really surprised
at how much these stain.
When I was trying to take it off,
my lips were bright pink.
I don't know if I'd ever use these again,
but they're cute.
I haven't reviewed a Too
Faced product in forever,
but it just released this
Born This Way Ethereal
Light smoothing concealer,
and I heard really good things about it.
It's supposed to be super
hydrating and smoothing.
I did not like the applicator on this,
not because of the shape,
but because it doesn't
pick up product that well.
This formula is actually really nice.
Even after blending it out
and setting it with powder,
you can still see that
luminosity in the concealer.
I don't know if it did much smoothing,
but I like the coverage it gave me
and how easy it was to work with.
This is the Dior Rouge Dior Forever
transfer-proof lipstick.
Not a liquid lipstick, a regular lipstick.
So you apply this like any other lipstick,
wait three minutes for the color to set,
and you should be left
with a long-wearing, transfer-proof lip.
I think this particular
shade was a bit patchy,
but I evened it out as much as I could.
I could not believe how well this worked.
I was expecting a lot of transfer
because this is a regular lipstick,
but the transfer was pretty minimal.
It also didn't feel
too drying on the lips.
I think this formula is really cool,
and I want to try out some other shades.